Muy buenas tardes pues es todo un gran
júbilo por parte de los marroquíes que
eran mayoría en este estadio aquí de
alto mama gran jolgorio a lo largo de
todo este partido muchísimo silbidos
cada vez que Portugal tenía la pelota
Así que fue bastante ensordecedor Y
seguramente hasta un poco perturbador
para los jugadores lusos el poder luchar
por este partido a lo largo de todos
estos 90 minutos por supuesto ese gol
que llegó de Marruecos ya en el minuto
42 como usted bien lo decía Rodrigo de
Siri pero sobre todo es una falla una
salida en falso por completo de Diego
costa el Arquero de Portugal en el
segundo tiempo Portugal tuvo mejores
ocasiones sobre todo con la entrada de
Cristiano Ronaldo finalmente en este
partido Gonzalo Ramos quien había
marcado ese triplete en el partido
anterior en octavos Hoy estuvo
completamente desaparecido y fue Ronaldo
quien de alguna manera le entró a este
partido con un poco más de peligrosidad
más incisivo pero finalmente parecía que
tampoco lo escuchaban
compañeros Portugal estuvo luchando el
partido hasta el final pero pues
Marruecos logró ya ese gol y luego
mantuvo la presión y mantuvo una defensa
férrea Ahora hay que decir lo más
Marruecos logra este momento histórico
por supuesto para su fútbol para el
fútbol árabe en realidad porque aquí
todos los Países Árabes van a estar
detrás de Marruecos en esa semifinal que
vendrá pero también Marruecos llega con
varios de sus jugadores al lesionados
entre ellos es ahí siquiera salió de
este partido lesionado y Bueno será la
gran duda vamos a ver cómo va esto para
las próximas semifinales esperando El
vencedor entre Inglaterra y Francia Ya
esta noche
[Aplausos]